this is where my barn was now everything
is gone
says Alexander as he inspects what
remains of the home and the life he and
his wife spent 35 years building
pro-russian forces from the donets
region occupied their Village in March
they looted the stories they were
drinking shooting they told us they
would be here forever they said we will
pay you back for our suffering you beat
us now we will beat you
Alexander shows us what remains of his
beehives
shelling killed and injured much of his
livestock what survived disappeared
during the battle
I don't know what to what to say
but no matter what Russia has done to us
we want to come home now
they destroyed Russian military truck
outside the smashed Village School where
Russian soldiers stayed
Russian packs gas masks and destruction
all that remain
volunteers distribute wood to those Keen
to start at least basic repairs on their
destroyed homes
cranian rocket climbs into the sky a few
kilometers away
cranian fighter jet circles overhead
[Music]
broken pastoral Life Below
Village after Village has been virtually
obliterated burnt out tanks squat among
splintered trees
there are dozens of villages like this
in the karazhon region which have been
completely destroyed gradually a few
people are returning to what remains of
their homes
but the situation is far from stable in
this region and Ukrainian military
forces are saying that they're dealing
with a potential renewed Russian advance
another rocket soars towards a Target in
Russian Hill territory
Vlad climbs through the gaping hole in
his grandmother's home
he's come to repair it so at least she
has protection from the approaching
winter cold
we couldn't contact her for months we
have to repair her home before the rain
starts we've had time to prepare they
won't beat us back again
the determined Spirit of innocent
civilians suffering deeply blackened
lives
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera hereson
region Southern Ukraine